notre bon président emmanuel macron a
plutôt feinter pour éviter de prendre
une décision dans ses paroles qui font
le buzz et qui excite tous les
journalistes de la terre de france et de
navarre sur ses excès de langage souvent
ça cache une décision qui n'a pas voulu
prendre comme la vaccination obligatoire
ça évite de mettre en place la
vaccination obligatoire si on regarde
les mesures de monsieur blanc caire sur
les tenues à l'école ça cache peut-être
d'autres problématiques qui se situe à
l'école
l'école et qui justement avec des tenues
qu'on a qui sont plutôt dirigés vers les
le sexe féminin oui généralement avec
quelques problématiques qu'on peut
trouver dans le milieu scolaire
notamment après les événements de sa
belle pâtit je pense que c'est pour
éviter de parler des sujets qui fasse
donc pour moi tout ça c'est un manque de
courage politique
[Musique]